Imagine prisoners that have spent their entire lives chained deep inside a cave.
They have been chained so that they cannot see behind themselves.
And they are forced to stare endlessly at the cave wall in front of them.
Behind them, a fire is burning.
And between the prisoners and the fire is a raised walkway.
Now imagine that each day, a menagerie of objects crosses the walkway,...
...animals and people carrying their wares to market.
Their shapes create an intricate shadow play on the wall in front of the prisoners.
This is the only world that the prisoners have ever known,...
...the shadows and the echoes of unseen objects.
Now imagine that a prisoner is released.
After some time adjusting to the blinding light,...
...the free prisoner will begin to experience the world outside of the cave for the very first time.
And it is like nothing he could have ever imagined.
With his new perception of the world,...
...the man would of course want to return to his friends to share his incredible discoveries.
But the prisoners cannot recognize their old friend.
He appears as all things do.
His voice is a distorted echo.
And his body is a grotesque shadow.
They cannot understand his fantastic stories of the world outside of the cave.
To them it will never exist.
This of course, does not make the world outside of the cave any less real.